cowboys and cowgirls cheered on as they
join the now weekly anti lockdown rally
in brazil's capital the numbers vary and
the count is always contested but
thousands flooded into brasilia from
cities and towns hundreds of miles away
it's noisy and raucous and it's utterly
defined forget social distancing forget
staying safe in fact forget kovat these
are the faithful supporters of President
Gerald Sandero who pour scorn on the
pandemic and is willing to ignore the
crisis engulfing his country his
supporters called him legend and his
arrival is pure theater circling the
crowd time and again in his helicopter
urged on from the ground
[Music]
finally he appears outside the
presidential palace to greet his adoring
fans sounds familiar
well Donald Trump is his hero and this
is pure Trump but it's not always so
upbeat he's facing allegations of
misconduct in office and Brazil is one
of the worst covert hit countries in the
world in truth on an ordinary day he
looks exhausted
and ill listening not engaging the
supporters telling him he is their
Savior these supporters now man camps in
the capital are there from all walks of
life they don't deny covered but they
think everything is a communist plot
that's Chinese and Brazilian communists
in fact anyone who doesn't support poles
Inara
of course I'm not stupid but it is not
this
we are here to support our president
because our president he's really since
the beginning really tough really strong
he is trying to expose the truth about
Kovac 19 but he is up against so many
people so many institutions that they
are not interested in telling people the
truth they are interested in keep
boosting the numbers up and keep people
hiding at home Brazil is now hugely
divided those who support the president
and those staring at a nightmare spread
of the kovat 19 virus when the numbers
keep rising every day
Stroh Ramsey skynews Brazilian